[Music]
when you use a google service your
information travels over the internet
between your app and various points of
internet infrastructure until it reaches
google servers
encryption helps prevent attackers from
eavesdropping on internet connections
and accessing sensitive content such as
your credentials emails and other
personal data
do you know how google encrypts data to
keep it safe stick around and we'll show
you
first things first what is encryption
well it's a mathematical process that
takes legible data as input and
transforms it so that is unreadable to
unauthorized parties
the encryption algorithm used is public
such as the advanced encryption standard
aes but execution depends on a key which
is kept secret to transform it back to
its original form you need to employ the
key google encrypts your data when it's
saved on a disk and when stored on
backup media and this is called
encryption at rest
it also encrypts data while it is moving
over the internet or traveling between
data centers which is called encryption
in transit
starting with data at rest several
layers of encryption are deployed to
protect users data
data is split into chunks each chunk is
encrypted with a unique data encryption
key these keys are stored with the data
and encrypted inside of google's central
key management service
google's key management service rotates
keys at least as frequently as 90 days
so in the very unlikely event that a key
were compromised it won't remain valid
for very long
how about a real-life example to put all
of this into context let's say a video
is uploaded to google drive that video
will not be stored entirely in a single
server but instead will be broken up
into chunks and then copied for
availability and performance
each of these chunks are encrypted and
have their own unique identifier
each piece is then stored across
multiple servers
as for data in transit google applies
several security measures to help ensure
the authenticity integrity and privacy
of data in transit
depending on the connection that is
being made google applies default
protections to data and transit to a
google data center for example
communications are secured between the
user and the google front end using tls
which is a cryptographic protocol
data is encrypted and authenticated in
transit at one or more network layers
when it moves outside the physical
boundaries of a google data center
customers in google cloud for example
may have additional requirements for
encryption of data especially in highly
regulated industries and they have
additional options such as managing
their own encryption keys
and because computers get better and
faster it becomes easier to perform the
complicated mathematical computations
needed to break encryption even the
mathematics behind this process known as
cryptanalysis can improve over time
making it easier to break encryption and
so to keep pace with this evolution
google has a team of world-class
security engineers tasked with following
developing and improving encryption
technology
our engineers take part in
standardization processes and in
maintaining widely used encryption
software such as boring crypto and ssl
library and chrome chromium android and
a number of other apps and programs
we regularly publish research in the
field of encryption so that everyone can
benefit from this shared knowledge
if you want to learn more check out the
links below and stay tuned for more on
discovering data centers